you know you could put anything in here
if you want a super flex
put it on your belt buckle let them know
what time it is
i mean
what's up gq my name is mclemore and
these
are my essentials
[Music]
first thing we got a louis vuitton
duffel bag murakami did this bag back in
2005
and i know that because i looked at this
bag for a long time
i love cherries they're delicious my
home group
and my recovery community happens to be
cherry hall
in seattle there's just something
special about it man
whoever had it before me took really
good care of it am i gonna give this to
like
my daughter to borrow for an overnight
like absolutely not she's five years old
this is
louis vuitton it's just not gonna happen
i'm not gonna share this with my kids
number one essential
[Applause]
next up is my android charger
just kidding i have an iphone i'm not
crazy this charger
is long you got to have the lawn charger
you never know when you're in a hotel
how close the outlet is going to be to
the bed
my wife steals these they just vanish
homie still this is like one of those
things that
it's kind of like sparkling water in
your fridge people that come to your
house just feel like they can
take sparkling water out of your fridge
which is fine but they also treat
chargers like it's sparkling water and
they'll just steal
from you um a lot of friends do that so
you gotta charge up
six foot cord can't go wrong
this is the black pepper from com de
garcon
i love the fragrance of comb dagar song
i think i have
all of them at this point i get
complimented like
what is that i just tell people that
it's a
ralph lauren so they don't smell like me
but the truth is it's come de garcon and
now everyone knows
[Music]
smells like a peppercorn sauce at a
nice steakhouse sweet touch of summer
a brisk winter this is my thing with
sprays
i do more of like a far away double
spray
kind of walk into it and then i do more
of a condensed
to the body spray and sometimes i might
even do
two of those trying to let it be known
when i walk into a room there goes that
dude
in that black pepper
[Music]
so this is more louis vuitton
that i put inside of the louis vuitton
bag in here
we have some gucci sunglasses
these you can actually kind of see my
eyes in them i prefer
sunglasses where you can't see where i'm
looking so i can just kind of
weekend at bernie's tom brady after he
won a super bowl
just kind of like no one knows what's
going on underneath here
but i prefer the incognito also inside
of the sunglass case
is something that i'm very proud of this
is
the mls cup champions the seattle
sounders can you guys get that are you
in there are you tight enough
is it dancing are the diamonds dancing
it's a pinky ring
it's a massive like i wear this for 15
minutes and my pinky is exhausted
like it needs a break i'm lucky to be a
partial owner
of the seattle sounders and if that
sounds like a flex
good
here i got my bogey boys golf balls i
have become obsessed with golf in the
last
two years and starting a brand called
bogey boys
these are our pro-v ones i actually drew
that little dog on the front of it
that little cute-ass dog playing golf
god what a character
these are our own balls and inside of
here more lv i have
bogey boys golf balls they got the bb on
them
and i always carry the special ball
this was given to me by my mother-in-law
thanks sam
[Music]
this is a candle it was a candle
probably at that point where we could
throw it away now
i need to re-up it's an ood o.u.d
by diptique hmm
it just smells like smells like the dead
of night
it smells like a fox pelt it smells like
a man's cave
this [ __ ] hits i love this candle i burn
it all the time
i would take this on the road i do take
this on the road
anywhere i go you know um any diner
just kind of dress it up boom put it
down
denny's like let me get an omelette and
a lighter
and you just kind of set the tone
doesn't matter where you're at it's a
nice restaurant with this candle
this right here is important if you're
going to play the game of golf
got to have it on you it is called a
range finder
mine's pretty busted probably justify
getting a new one
you look in this little thing and you
can see the
yardage of how far away you are
to the flag very important to get your
yardage right
in theory you should be able to share
this
on the golf course in actuality most
dudes
stand about five feet away from each
other with their own range finder
getting their own yardage you never
trust somebody else when they tell you
that you're playing with you never like
oh yeah it's 145 to the pin
let me just make sure okay don't trust
humans
[Music]
really didn't come here to plug my own
clothing brand i did not do that i did
that was not my intention but if we're
talking about essentials i have to have
my bogey boys hat brand new i love this
thing
we went through a lot of hats to find
the perfect one it's
old school kind of has an 80s vibe it's
the perfect
green it's like bottle green that
matches the bogey boys socks these
aren't brand new i've been wearing these
socks they are
washed they got our all over dog leg
print
on them very comfortable very cozy i
am not super inspired by the current
style of golf but
if you go back to like the 70s you go
back to the 80s
that is what inspires me so i'm like who
had the best hats back in the day
like lee trevino had the best hats and
it just has that feel to it man it has
that retro feel but it also doesn't feel
like you're dressing up in grandpa's
golf closet it feels 20 21
but with like a hint of the past as well
this right here is my watch it is a
ap audemars piguet
see the problem is like no one knows how
to pronounce this [ __ ] properly
like rappers have been butchering the
names of like
fancy luxury items for a really long
time myself included
like i have a maybach and i go into the
dealership
i call it a maybach and they're like yes
maybach i'm like
no rick ross actually told me a long
time ago that this [ __ ] was called a
maybach
i get obsessive about anything that i
start to research
so for me once i start like googling
watches
it gets dangerous i have probably
five watches maybe maybe six
so i'm not like a collector collector i
wear them
i appreciate them i try not to buy more
of them
which is which is challenging
this right here little bogey boys bag
[Music]
you know you could put anything in here
again if you want a super flex
put it on your belt buckle let them know
what time it is
i mean you show up to a work meeting
like that
you're probably not going to come back
to work the next day but you made a
statement
gq thank you so much for coming to my
house
coming inside my room and looking at my
stuff
my essentials much love peace